I must advise against this the odds of
survival a 682 1 no choice Threepio my
sister's in trouble are to get it
everything okay but I'm not sure yet
hurry you're our only hope it took you
so long well this just got interesting
follow my lead
never underestimate the power of
imagination
hey youtubers it's Charlie so surprised
star wars video duracell posted this ad
for the holiday shopping season for some
of their toys and we know that Disney
works really close with toy
manufacturers when it comes to making
ads so what does this promo say about
what's going on in the film so this is
going to be a lot of speculation mixed
with things that we already know about
the film so just careful for potential
spoilers for the film but I remind you
that a lot of this is just speculation
so no worries so what is this little
girl wearing the Daisy Ridley costume
wielding Luke Skywalker's lightsaber
from Return of the Jedi say about the
force awakens well I think that it
answers a really big question that
everyone has had about Daisy Ridley's
character one that she's for sensitive
and two that she has something to do
with the sky Walker family there's been
a lot of people recently that have been
wondering about Luke Skywalker's
relation to kylo Ren is Luke Skywalker
going to be the villain in these next
couple of films I'll say flat out hell
no to that there's already been pictures
that have leaked of luke skywalker's
costume from the movie I'm not going to
post them here just because they are
super spoilery but i think that kylo Ren
and Daisy Ridley share a very special
familial connection to the Skywalker's
but it is to Leia Han not to Luke
remember there is another Skywalker who
is for sensitive it's just that when
they posted the first promo and then
they aired the trailer everyone was like
oh I wanted Daisy Ridley to be a Jedi
just like John boyega well just because
she's not holding a lightsaber and the
promos doesn't mean that she's not going
to become a Jedi I said in my trailer
video but i don't think that kathleen
kennedy who would try to introduce a lot
more powerful females to the Star Wars
universe and not let any of them become
Jedi but if you want to be super literal
about this commercial you could
speculate that Daisy really will use
Luke Skywalker's lightsaber at some
point in the film now I think that we
would rather see her wield a dual bladed
lightsaber because she has that Tusken
Raider looking staff there but who knows
this is just the first film in a new
trilogy so I don't think we're going to
be seeing crazy Jedi stuff till the
second film when it comes to New Jedi
dark side characters I think the first
film is mostly going to be focusing on
john-boy yoga's character wielding
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber in kylo
Ren here with his own self built
lightsaber but just get hype and I'm not
expecting any like big big star wars
trailers to drop between now and the
movie coming out but I do think there'll
be more short promos
there'll be more toy stuff like this
that'll tell us things about the film so
between all that stuff I mean we'll
learn a lot more about the film and just
reminder if there's any confusion about
big bads in the new film andy's circuses
character is playing supreme leader
snoke the supreme leader of the first
order he is technically going to be like
the new emperor figure who also really
won't show up to the second film I think
the character that I'm most hype about
though is Captain phasma like Gwendoline
Christie is just so amazing especially
in Game of Thrones speaking of which
there is a new game of Thrones video
coming tonight that I'm working on so be
sure to subscribe to get that and if
there's any other Star Wars bonus videos
you guys want me to do in the next week
or so just let me know in the comments
there are a bunch of video games coming
in November's especially battlefront i
might do stuff for that on my game
channel i'm still getting a little bit
settled in my new apartment so why guys
way for all that stuff to post you can
click here to enter the star wars
infinite trailer loop you know just like
make the concept like oh my god it's so
beautiful face and then you can click
here for last night's episode of the
walking dead deep deep dive into the
craziest character on the show thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight me
me me me me